is there anybody in the car you want
just you want just get away from the car
cuz I don't want the wires God forbid
there's power going to them they're just
telephone wires I got you I'm
electrician I know what I got you I'm
not so I just want to play it safely I
live across the street we happen to just
catch this I don't know he said that the
the trees should be chapped up know I I
stopped whatever I had to stop I stopped
and then when I saw the car hit me this
is another thing I've been living here
for 20 years that tree you cannot see
anybody coming until you pull out into
the intersection gotcha all right but
I'm not you know that's definitely
that's a burl code thing so I mean I
know if somebody filed a complaint with
them they could definitely do something
about it yeah um you were driving this
car yeah you're okay yeah you're fine no
injuries at all still I'm okay do you
want first aid to come and check you out
no no just a little Bruce of leg that's
it you sure you don't want first aid no
I'm okay
positive yeah I'm pissed off
too okay all right I mean nobody wants
this shade but happens at least
we're alive right yeah yeah no
definitely um all right you have your
driver's license on you registration
insurance and all
that
[Applause]
this
is
are you look for
that hey Kayla you want just grab LIC
registration insurance and then
everybody's information that was in the
car and where they were
seated I got this
one
[Applause]
I'm good thank
you no we're good I appreciate
it so where my car my car is going to be
toe to yeah so I don't know who our toe
company is today it's either going to be
Midland or Jersey Shore they're both in
Bayville okay all
right and then can some me a ride to my
friend the house yes
okay okay so I have my can I take my
keys out yeah you can take the keys out
yep don't try to start yeah let me let
me do it I have a wallet attached to
these and that's where my driver's
license is I I don't know where it is
now it didn't tell put that put that
[Music]
in there you
go but then I had a I have a wallet that
was attached to it yeah it has like my
what's that that's a big wallet oh it's
smaller yeah that it has my drive's
license is it in the
car that's what I'm trying to find all
right is the car registered in your name
yeah so your name's on the
registration yeah okay so yeah if you
want just give me the registration and
the insurance card my name and uh my
husband's
name oh my God
call Sergeant
Morris hey I need some help over
here uh completely down and we need help
with some
traffic going to be a motor in
Springfield everybody Kayla no injuries
in the other car no not so far not yet
it's just one driver no one else n no
injuries
good H they're they're here
now Temple yeah they're uh they're
rolling up now so they'll be able to
help me
out
all right sounds good all right
bye are you able to find him man no
no you want me to look through it you're
a little flustered you just got an
accident so yeah you can looking for but
I have a little wallet that's what I
could I put my stuff and I can't find my
little wallet either either fell
somewhere or left in the
house
power yeah these ain't power wires right
no look like just cable yeah I think
it's we good just Telecom okay um so you
don't have registration or Insurance on
you Joe you need a squad uh no they said
they're good
so I know she showed she said she's
fine you got some blood on the on the
back back of you too I saw on the back
of your pants are you sure you don't
want first because I have my P oh okay
gotta you don't want first is that what
it is I have my per I have no idea but
you I'm fine you're positive yeah cuz
they could just come and look at you
real quick no I I look okay all right
and where were you trying to aggravated
about I would be too hell I'd be real
aggravated a nice day going to work
cleaning my houses and now all the
I got
you
um I don't know I think so I don't know
what is my little wall what is your name
Brennan that's my husband's name what's
your name ra raphaela
raphaela when you have a second this guy
is paid off and you see my name and his
name but he all paid off got you have a
picture of your driver's license by
Chance the other one comes put over here
walking
up I just saw
you so it's in a little wallet somewhere
you have first day coming out yeah
they're coming out all right they all
said they're good but I don't care
picked up this is bad she has some blood
on her legs
[Music]
so I guess it's in my
house you don't have it no okay unless
you fell here somewhere all right no
worries you want just stay with her can
you run is this guy driving the other
car what's that can you run on the yeah
we're going to try to have it gotcha
okay here's his stuff if you want to
take yeah I'll take all that and it's a
brand new one too they they just renew
because my birthday was in January what
was your name ra rafella rafhael r r r
a how do you spell your first name r a
yep f a l and Rea yeah yeah what your uh
middle initial S S date of
birth January
1578 10 January oh January 15 okay 78 78
and your Social
Security the whole number yeah the whole
number
yeah I think it's six H well that
I she H pretty hard I think she should
get checked out
you don't think what she should c yeah
she is they're
coming is on your driver's license is it
is it your maiden name or is it Rea no
this is my middle
name my last name is that's my marriage
name I'm
sorry okay let me take that back
all right if you want my driver's
license is valid everything is good I
don't know where my Little King I I got
you no worries if you want can you hang
out over here on the grass cuz and and
take whatever you need out of the
vehicle cuz they're going to be moving
it
so you can leave the keys in the
ignition all right we're going to get
back to this body cam in a second but I
want to take a minute to talk about
something else that happens all the time
workplace injuries if you get hurt at
your job whether it's a slip and fall a
mechanical failure negligence of your
co-workers something hits you you're
going to need a trusted law firm in your
corner enter Pon Le hockey Giordano a
firm that is a heavyweight in the
industry that wins all different kinds
of injury cases yes workplace but also
accidents Social Security Disability
injuries they have a track record of
recovering over $1 billion for their
clients and they have won over a 100,000
cases they have 250 years of combined
experience how amazing is that so you
can check out ponle hockey Giordano at
ponle hockey.com
ELC body cam or you can pick up the
phone and call them at 833 669 4043 all
right let's get back to the body
cam just clean my car what's that just
clean everything I wash all the
SE stay here yeah that can all stay
there and just leave your keys in the
car
too stay there let me take this
stuff hey sge is
jcpnl let me see who pole it is it
should be jcp's Pole right
now what is that that's usually perou is
there another on there no 1850 that was
it all C unless it's
just
hey buddy you a driver of this car yes
sir okay we want to explain a little bit
what happened I came from this way
okay doing what my 25 or 30 what it was
she was coming this way I glanced to my
left saw her coming I cranked it to the
right so instead of hitting me cuz she
was coming for me she hit my back gotcha
you got me so she was coming from the
stop signs I would had no stop signs
yeah you had the right away I had the
right away okay okay right all right
beautiful just you in the car yeah
awesome all right you you injured at all
I feel sore I'm okay all right well
first day is coming out so take a couple
hours before he kicks in exactly yeah so
they're coming out and if you were to go
to hospital later so I'm just telling me
you're in a vehicle accident and all
that stuff County about it no not yet I
just County see who p is and have them
come out and then we'll go from there
take look it up they'll have it yeah
they'll have it on file it's phone compy
there what's the phone number bt50 PB
bt50 PD PB PB
PB 289
count can you look up a PO number who
got to come out for this just tell them
it's 520 Motors what was it B uh BT 50
PB you go the number make figure
out it's going to be Bravo Tango 50 Papa
Bravo going to be on the property of 520
motor
D this here yeah
yeah feel okay though how was that hit
you pretty
hard doesn't like but I'm
okay just upset I know I understand
we're so scary you don't know I know
it's very scary but luckily you both are
still here you know that's just look at
the bra side yeah but I stop at I stop
sign I don't understand did you
yeah is there did I drive very careful I
stop
everywhere and you were coming from
Springfield right down that way at this
point I don't even know what
I I you always want to get checked out
only takes 10 mes hour of a crash to uh
CA Whiplash so it's always nice to get
checked out you know I'm not going to
the hospital I have to go to
[Applause]
work
yeah how's it going man you all
right okay what
happened this happen you didn't see the
stop sign I saw that stop sign
but oh there's no there's you didn't
stop the at this the way this accident
is it definitely didn't stop so I didn't
I didn't see any any car yeah okay so
how fast do you think you were going
when you went through
it I was driving around here I
everything happen so fast I don't know
sure need I'm sorry that we don't need a
squad we're
good want goosal I don't want to go okay
you'll just sign off then
okay uh give ETA on the
ambulance County from 22
can I have an ETA on the ambulance
please
minutes I
am so now I uh can I walk
there
so then I figure out my son can go and
pick me up we could we could drive you
when everything's set and down yeah I'm
going to go there and I wait for my son
to pick me up I don't want to stay here
I don't want to be looking at
this I don't I don't even know how that
happened was I was driving all over the
Sun a car came I don't know stop sign
here stop sign there trees everywhere I
I don't I know how that
happened yeah I can walk there how far I
am from
there can you give me a ride for my
friend house yes we can't release you
just yet though okay she's going to give
me a ride to your house
huh
that no the lady that is waiting uh to
the hairport to get done and then she
said she can give me she can drop me off
at my friend's
house not in my house but my friend
house and then my son can go and pick me
up
there
[Music]
yeah up whatever at least my
last I just want to get out of here I
just want to go hang out in your house
for a little bit I feel anxiety when I
places like
[Applause]
that oh I was about to say at
no no I
know is that did you know what year this
is like
that all right uh so can you send me the
address again so I make sure I have the
right
address ma'am do you know the year of
your vehicle thank you do you know the
year of your vehicle 2015
15 all right I'm going to my friend's
house you can't leave just yet though
there's a form you have to sign before
we release
you
cuz I don't have a Chet I'm cold do you
want to sit in the back of the car just
to stay
warm where's the form so I get signed
the ambulance has to bring
[Applause]
it but if you want we could have you sit
in the back of the car just so you're
not out
here you know it's warmer in
there
what time the ambulance is going to be
here so I can sign these it should be
like four more
minutes maybe less
[Music]
have
up Zer
[Music]
you
what is this place exactly the town this
is Pine
Beach and you're on Motor Road all right
so here's this stuff
backless
[Music]
you're what's a good phone number for
you
[Music]
I do a favor and just take your
sunglasses off real quick just I go look
at your
hives check
out there an accident we got to make
sure nobody's Under the Influence but
you look fine
so and you needed a ride somewhere yeah
where' you need a ride I need to right
to my friend's house and then my son's
going to Piat me up there where's your
friend's house
get the case number right on the back of
this
okay
[Music]
please yeah there's no way the your case
is going to
beit the 4
[Music]
you
the
know uh I think so I don't know where
they press here yeah yeah I know where
that's
at oh how far is that from here right
down the road not far okay yeah so can I
just walk down
you guys can take me there yeah we can
take you there yeah all right it's just
H for when my my son came he can come
and pick me up okay all right Beautiful
cuz my husband is who came on as one
gotcha who's your friend that lives
on huh your friend that lives on who's
that I have a girlfriend that lives
there so she said I can't stay there
until my friend until my brother pick me
up gotta okay
all right
perfect uh first aid is just rolling up
now so they're going to check you out
real quick make sure you're all good and
you can sign off saying you don't want
first aid and whatnot what you got in
your mouth is that a gumball I was
wondering I thought your face was
swollen do you want to be checked out by
us no I'm fine okay you don't want your
Ral take or anything all right no I'm
fine I I just got to okay if anything
starts to bother you later or something
doesn't feel right right you can call
okay other drive that
van he's in the driver's door right now
okay sir we're with the first aid do you
want to be checked out by first aid or
you think you're good I think I'm okay
all right anything bothers you later you
can call 911 okay okay very go all right
thanks for coming out I appreciate
it what refusing yeah they didn't sign
though okay they only sign if they
checked them out and they refus to go to
the hospital they're refusing to be
checked out and everything yeah it's on
video thank you appreciate it have a
good one um the poll we know who it is
waai just ask an
update
yeah this is just a telepo
wire I'm going grab that from the front
pull it out a little bit and then hook
it up okay do you need fire check all or
are you good uh yeah maybe that 289 I
advise com we going to send someone out
to check and see if it's they're
wired they said they advise Comcast they
don't know whose fall is so they advise
Comcast to come out and see if it's
theirs so as of right now we have no
idea it's not FiOS it might
actually that might be F did you see
Jeff video not yet he has it yeah he's
got look at it right now okay uh this is
this is Cable cable coax yeah it's
Comcast it's Comcast comcraft all right
they're coming out cool all right
Comcast is coming so
it's
just I know I'm sorry
[Music]
going to take me there we are but we
just have to wait a little bit
[Applause]
[Music]
I
so I don't want to come closer to go ler
in
thatu I'm like you know
what
[Music]
hard
done
somebody just take me there please I
have to wait on
him what he's
doing I just want to right there so my
son can pick me up where's your son now
he's working
okay
so they ask if I need anything right and
I said no so I can just
walk um we'll ask
him
if you
want hold on let me
ask your friend doesn't drive
right okay taking care of her mom is
sick
okay
he's just going to grab her uh business
cards and then you could drive her over
there I'm going to stay here with s
okay uh she's going to so just throw on
GPS
any starting and ending modes
yeah
no
problem 2 4
6 thanks
app this is going to be uh our
department information phone number's on
here um this is going to be your case
number when you call up your accid
reports you're ready in about 7 to 10
business days um so I would notify your
insurance company today that you got
involved in a motor vehicle accident
okay and tell them they got to wait for
the s report to be ready so like I said
we'll be if you need anything El all
right okay yeah all right no problem
have a good one sir this is where the to
the car is going to be so whenever you
want to go pick it up if you want to
pick it up and the insurance companies
going ask you where it's at that's where
it's going to be it'll also be marked on
the report okay okay how do I get to you
she's going to take we're going to give
you a ride thank you okay all right
thank you so much I'm sorry about no it
happens listen it's an accident that's
why they're called a 2 to one that's it
everyone no listen people can't be
replaced cars can this week and I just
you just say I'll be giving a ride to
everything in my car a female to that's
why you have whatever the address is 70
JFK it's the whole purpose of it 1011
started you pay all that money for all
those years I mean might as well use it
I'm giving somebody a ride yeah all
right uh just make sure you take her bag
and put it in the front with you okay
okay all right you're good to go thank
you if you need anything let us know
okay what way do you want me go down
that
way
Pur thank you so much you're
welcome oh my God thank you you're
welome remember okay if you don't feel
good at any point just make that phone
call okay get checked out get check but
I'm okay I'm not D or anything it's just
my leg it normally comes later on like
tonight or something you'll start
feeling aches and pains so if it hurts
real bad I'd go to the hospital M all
right yep of course take it easy okay
all right my son should be here in a
little all right beautiful I'm glad
you're
okay all
right
County from 22
294 1011 my ending mileage it is 1